so if you aren't familiar with the trash
taste Awards which you probably are if
you're watching episode 150 it's the
yearly recap of all the best moments of
the show the past year from the specials
to the stuff off camera a little bit and
just the highlights of all the episodes
yeah and so we have made some new
categories previously we had many
categories but we've added some little
fun new ones taking out some some they
really didn't hit as hard as we liked
and we're just going to go through all
the moments and talk about the Year this
is great I love the trash days Awards
because I actually get reminded of all
the dumb and weird [__] we said we did
because yeah for me and I remember any
of them we say a lot of [__] and it's
especially during the nomination stage
where we go through it and uh we kind of
realize oh who said that
so many moments where one of us is like
did I say that
I don't feel like I said that but also
the clips right there yeah I guess I did
say yeah
yeah no guys probably deep faked right
we we would have no idea AI generated
it's AI generated but yeah this year we
tried to chose categories that best
encapsulated everything and all the
moments that happened in this year and I
feel like this year was the year that
was encapsulated by us kind of like
traveling around a lot you know
the first two years we were definitely
just stuck in Japan and we tried to make
as much content from Japan as possible
but doesn't it feel [__] insane
thinking back that this is the year that
we kind of got to meet a lot of like
other fellow content creators who we
like respected for like the longest time
and uh we kind of realized how much
trash taste had grown this year
especially during our La trip I remember
uh like way during like the first couple
of weeks we were like oh yeah this
little podcast maybe last like 30
episodes yeah it'll just dip like all
the other ones look at us 150 baby
that's
somehow good at being consistent but
we're also very inconsistent with after
dark this year we did way less after
dark but that's you know not from a lack
of trying we're just all over the place
traveling we're all doing our own things
too it's kind of hard to line it all up
but trash takes is nailed every week
though yeah thank God we still haven't
missed an episode we still have not
missed an episode in three years and
counting you know what I'll give myself
a medal for that one right that's that's
impressive no season breaks we just
we're back to back every single week oh
yeah I don't know how we've done it yeah
I feel like there's been some close
calls we were like we have two days to
get an episode out yeah
we got it man yeah we uh just landed in
La we have two days we have no equipment
and we have nothing to add what the [__]
are we going to do yeah and somehow we
still managed to get an episode out and
not miss a week yeah yeah it's uh I
think it's been a very very busy year
for all three of us on trash days and
outside of trash taste as well so I
think some of the awards nominations
don't just represent stuff that has
happened on like let's say our personal
trash taste challenge but stuff that's
happened in the wider trash taste
Universe yeah the TCU whatever the TC
the ttcu the tccu whatever you want to
call it you know I like how we have kind
of a match this weird kind of like
sitcom Vibe with any people who come on
and you know we always refer to mailing
and then he's like what do you guys say
about me
your laughter
it's always good fun yeah we've got the
canned laughter which is Nabi like
everything every now and then
yeah we have a lot to go through so uh
let's let's check them out that was the
first one oh okay so uh just a list of
the categories really quickly we have
the hottest take of the year of course
well we're starting things
best starter context clip screen grab of
the year most a general moment US state
we will not revisit that's a new one
uh saltiest moment most monkey moment
yes wildest guest episode because we
definitely had a lot of those uh best
story biggest clown biggest Chad all
caps biggest W of the Year very few to
count uh best nickname best meme best
Deez Nuts moment because uh I feel there
was like a Renaissance of Deez Nuts
jokes yeah yeah uh best strip best
argument most wholesome moment most
privileged moment biggest I made it the
[__] up moment best after dark moment
and of course the best trash taste
episode yeah so this is a pretty stacked
Awards and I feel like this encompasses
everything that happened this year yeah
so shall we get right on it let's just
jump right here
the hardest take of the Year
trash taste is famous for a lot of our
hot takes uh controversial takes uh and
uh often we don't know what's gonna
become an actual hot take until the
episode airs because we just say [__] do
you ever have that feeling uh when we're
recording when you say something like oh
that's not gonna go down well you know
and then it doesn't I think you say
something completely normal you're like
why do they hate me for this yeah I
think I think that I think the more the
hot takes that have been birthed were
the ones where it didn't start off with
I know this is a hot take but it just
ends up not being a hot day and then
just something you're just like yeah I
think of this I don't know I had I had a
few this year where I'm like I know it's
all my opinion but I'm like I know this
is going to be a hotel there is there
are some things I feel like the audience
takes turn bagging on us they'll have a
month or it's like let's [__] on Joey's
opinions and then it's gone and then
it's me and then they just take it and
turn it they're like all right now I'm
thinking dance takes not that good
anymore it's a great antagonist every
single yeah
some there's always some hot tape let's
go through the nominations yeah
so this year we had oranges are the
worst flavor known to mankind orange is
the worst flavoring known to men I think
orange is like orange what which I
believe is the exact quote that kind of
said you know do you know what's weird I
literally you said this so long ago I
literally thought this was last year
well this is gonna happen a lot I think
this awards that where we confused last
year and the sugars were in the same set
yeah yeah so I think that's like a hard
way to memorize it yeah um but yeah I
did say this I stand by my opinion yeah
orange is the worst flavor known to
mankind I'll be pissed off if this went
uh we also got uh a guest one which is
Emily taking the meat out of her arm
that's [__] up what the [__] I was
like is this what is that racism if I
get Ramen I take out the meat
what do you mean the big difference this
year is that because we had so many
guest episodes we could actually bring
in what our guests have said on our
podcast as well so we're sharing we're
sharing the hot takes between everyone
this year it's not just not just the
three boys uh We've also got a I'm not
I'm not proud of this one ever ever is
not a Mecca anime by Yours Truly Ava for
me is really weird because it's like at
first glance it tries to present itself
as a Mecca yeah but then the further you
go along you realize it's not a Mecca
it's just a [__] sci-fi I just I
can't believe you just said this I
remember the exact moment this was
happening because we were in a heated
argument about whether Attack on Titan
uh is a Mecca anime or not uh then out
of nowhere like you just drop this
bombshell yeah and I don't know where
this came from this is you know this is
one of those things where it sounded
great in my head and then the moment it
came out of my mouth my brain just went
you [__] why did you say that that's
half of my jokes and then last but not
least we've all got God's opinion of God
preferring the latest seasons of Game of
Thrones
oh
I prefer the later seasons of Game of
Thrones [__] oh God genuinely
do you know what's funny sometimes I say
some takes that I know are going to be
hot takes I don't even think this is
like my hottest take of the year but
like it surprised me the [__]
reaction I got for this take just
because I it's it is that [__] I don't
think it is I don't know
I've never even I've never even seen
Game of Thrones and I know it's a [__]
take I'm hoping that you know because
mine is very easy to have a stance on
oranges but maybe if you haven't seen
Game of Thrones you might not give a
[__] about this takes there isn't a I I
don't think there's a person who hasn't
had an orange I'm hoping that people
will hate God's opinion so much that
they will outnumber the people who care
about oranges Kai is this do we have
only four nominations for this one okay
we have more nominations another slide
okay so we also have a couple more uh
got using light mode you dark mode
[__] play [__] up too much okay
hi I'm I'm a live mode user yes I'm I'm
out of myself right now okay I know of
course this is bad of course I knew this
was going to be a hot take this wasn't
surprising but you know what I still use
light mode look look let me go let me go
on Twitter right now guys let me let me
go
there we go let me let me let me go on
YouTube okay there we go there we go
have you got any question why you have
[__] eyesight it's probably because of
that yeah I need this to give me like to
find you make me see things better
honestly honestly I just I need like I
need live all pastries are the are bred
by Joey yeah uh I don't even remember
seeing this to be honest fair enough and
uh all sports are the same oh my God
I mean it is it is good it is good well
what's what's the difference I mean like
I know the difference but like isn't it
the same concept with football
[Music]
I mean it's not that far off let's be
honest here you know what I hope that
one wins all right all right well we
have some really strong contenders right
off the bat all right there's some
terrible takes but which one did you
vote as the hottest aka the worst or
shittiest take of the Year what's your
money on boys what are you thinking I'm
thinking it's either going to be the
orange one I want it to be the orange
one I have wanted to be Sydney or Game
of Thrones
I have a feeling it's between orange
Game of Thrones
um
yeah yeah yeah let's find out
and the winner is
oranges are the worst
wait
is there a tie on this one
this has never happened before to tie
with guards
[Music]
wait wait what was the breakdown [__] 20
for the top two holy [__]
okay oh my God it's followed by a gun
preferring the latest Seasons
[Music]
okay okay proven I have the best takes
on trash tastes for this year for this
year the best taste this year listen to
me more okay
I'm I'm surprised about the light mode
one because I'm not are you are you not
no because like it's like same thing
with oranges right like there isn't a
single person or there's very few people
who don't have you know mobile phones
nowadays right especially smartphones
and it's just like a common meme on the
internet now that light mode is [__] but
so it's like it's it's a general
understanding it's not an understanding
I just still I'm wondering what oranges
did to hurt Connor as a kid because I've
never it just tastes bad I just never
seen someone so feminently hate oranges
like Hannah hates oranges more than like
some like atrocious things that happen
there's a lot of things to hate in the
world yeah you chose orange
is just so bad on artificial oranges are
bad you're not allowed to talk anymore
you got the worst take I was very happy
to be in Florida and to tell them their
oranges suck absolutely